when you get a group of people together
when you do an event and you've come to
some of my events you've seen it right
you help take people to a new level of
confidence and motivation and that's
great but unless you do something while
you're in that state of confidence and
motivation you go home and you fall back
down where you work and you're going to
take their confidence to a new level
together but after three hours you're
gonna go home they're going to fall back
down to where they were and it's just
going to be this little blip unless you
get them to do something and then you
end it with the reminder again of why
they're here it's like your job is to
challenge their perspective they're
coming in because they have a message
the world and you're ending with they
have a message for the world when you
can see the fears in the Mirage or the
ahana they're like oh my gosh I can't
believe I did this like that's why
they're there at the workshop not to
learn how to edit a video but to start
to get their message out and that you've
helped them take that first step will be
something they remember the worst is one
person because if nobody shows up you
can go home right it's like it's not the
end of the world nobody showed up it's
fine nobody knows what happens it's like
if one person shows up is like oh it's
like our Host this event and you're the
only one here okay I can't go home yeah
I gotta stay here this is awkward okay
let's help you now I did it and they
didn't kill me actually
listen Yuko at the moment there was go
to Union Station and like make a quick
video now we're here talking about you
delivering a workshop Halfway Around the
World to women and teaching them things
like the Yuko from a few years ago
wouldn't have even thought that that was
possible
all right you guys back all right how
are we doing what's up what's on your
mind how can I help oh I'm doing
absolutely amazing thank you so much for
your invite I'm so happy to be here and
very nervous
you all right you've had such a growth I
mean it's fun when people come back for
round two around three because I
remember the first time you came here we
didn't actually get it on video but you
I think we have a picture of it yeah
where you came in and we're like super
nervous and super shy and I gave you a
challenge to
was it make a video at Union Station or
go talk to somebody at Union Station
yeah something and then you did it and
and just like get in in front of the
camera was super scary or nervous and
now you're doing it and making regular
content and it's it's been amazing it's
been really amazing watching your
journey I love your homework your
homeworks are awesome amazing too once
everyone told me you know it gives you
once you give me your homework
I must do it good and then I was
sweating before I took the camera pulled
the camera out at the Union Station
I had to just tell myself five minutes
it's gonna be okay
I gotta get it done
I must get it done
everyone's watching
and then as soon as Paul the camera
right and then just
it was okay actually
right so I was so afraid of like when I
I wanted to take a video film video so
bad and then I wanted to in my mind I
wanted to show women to have more
confidence to take a video in front of
in public I think it's a lot of courage
to do that
and then I I wanted to be more confident
like I said you know four three four
years ago
and I knew somehow I had to do your
homework I had to do it take a video
and I did it
and they didn't kill me actually
I didn't kill you I hope not okay no no
so I I still want since then I just like
every time I feel nervous just you know
take the phone start filming I just like
you know what when I started one action
I'm sure I help one woman in this world
who is struggling with just low
self-confidence
want to live a life who they are they
can somehow
but maybe somebody seen that person see
my video
and then just like oh if you go he's
doing it
I can do that
so I always have The Voice have the
image that encourages me
to do more
so I love it well let's give you some
more homework today what's up what do
you want to give well I don't know
what's on your mind how can I help what
do we what are we working through so I
can give you some more homework okay so
I am going back to Japan
January okay and then this time I just
don't want to go just to visit to Japan
so I decided to have a seminar in the
workshop let's go for women let's go to
build confident in Japan you're on a
world tour now this is great and I know
World Tour
and then I happen to myself I really
like editing video okay but I'm not tech
savvy lady
so I but it's like thanks to app
right phone apps so I found myself it's
easier to do editing and then the more
edit the more I I find it have fun and
then some people is just starting to see
like
how do you do that
right and then that reminds me like okay
reminds me five six years ago I see your
video some other people's creators video
just like how they do that I want to
just spread my word
right and I don't know how I'm not tech
savvy and then there's the app show up
and I start into teaching myself
but now I find it there are some women
especially my age 50s and up
they have no idea how to use phones and
app they cannot even learn through
watching YouTube and Google
so I just like
I can teach you guys because I know your
struggle
because they when they are having hard
time to learn
their self-esteem goes down
but when they're learning something they
can learn something even if like okay
one cut to cut okay I transition while
the screen's flipping
and they're so happy I was happy so so
your Workshop is going to be teaching
teaching women in Japan 50 60 50 60
maybe late 40s yeah late 40s how to make
content yeah and have confidence by
making content yeah which uh video app
short editing video for beginners okay
I like it that's cool thank you so so
then what's the struggle is it how to
find people is it how to promote it is
it what content to put up is it location
like what where what's next uh I already
have four people okay sign up because
Max six people so tight okay yeah and
then uh I have a place but the my uh
things I need you to coach is
uh I know I T I don't want to teach just
editing
I want to just do helping uh I don't say
confidence so
you mentioned the other day at movement
maker that 101 q a session things
and I just like you know what I want to
do I want to teach how to build to be
act confidence or how to feel confident
this is how you you can do how
but I just like
maybe if I turn into that the things is
q a how can I help
what do you need instead of what I'm
telling them what to do how long is the
event uh three hours so one first an
hour and a half probably I'll teach how
to edit
but I want to turn into
q a
things I want to help out
so what is a great how do I yeah yeah
okay so I got some ideas here okay first
off you want to think what do you want
them to leave with so the big idea
around this is not editing its
confidence yes and you get confidence by
what by learning a new skill by
expressing yourself by sharing your
story by having a message that you want
to try to get into the world like what's
the main theme that we're wrapping this
thing in
good question what's the main things so
that's important right what's the main
theme well it
are they coming because
and you've got four people and and six
great but but this could be this could
be a World Tour this could be you know
you bring it back to Canada you've done
it you've done it we did we've done it
it was fun yeah it's like what's the
main like they're gonna get confidence
but is are they getting confidence
because
they're afraid to do something and now
you're going to show them that they can
just go off and do it are they getting
confidence because they have a story
inside them that they want to get out to
the world and start to share and they're
they don't know how to do that are they
getting confidence because they feel
their Tech you know they're Limited in
their Tech and you're gonna now show
them hey you don't need to have Tech you
can use these apps to make it easy like
and it's going to be all of those things
like what's the main message that you're
gonna gain confidence through what like
when so that they know but also you can
focus the workshop on helping them
achieve a result okay so you're gonna
get confidence through
what I want to help to tap tap into
inside what they have inside too so it's
like I want to help to like whatever you
have an inside inside
it's okay you don't need to hide it
so like I want to just those girls
eventually feel free to be themselves
like feel free to show what they really
like
how they think yeah so is it about just
being free to share something and be on
camera and do the do the scary thing or
is it about
sharing a message for other people to
learn from I think sharing message is
more likely
so it's like for people who have like a
book on their bucket list some people
they they want to write a book just to
say that they wrote a book just to have
done it just to have the experience of I
have a book and others want to write a
book because they want to make an impact
so you're you're
you're teaching video editing skills but
that's not really the thing that you're
teaching you're teaching them to have
confidence that just the video editing
is how you're going to be doing it cool
but the confidence to film yourself on
camera
because other people can learn from your
message or because it's scary and you
should do like jumping out of an
airplane yeah it's scary it is scary
I've done it no never never but there's
no message to the world necessarily in
that right it's just you doing something
scary yeah right so filming a video you
could do it as it's just something it's
something scary to do doesn't mean you
have to get ever get good at it but it's
just something scary and by doing scary
things you build your confidence yes
that's one path versus
uh no the point of sharing this story
isn't just to do the scary thing it's
because you're going to help somebody
else out that in explaining what you've
went through it's going to serve
somebody else who's watching that video
even if four people watch a video maybe
one of those people it's a life-changing
message for them
which which one do we want to be
teaching I think that one this one
we were in like VR he's like grab the
ball over my hand yeah okay okay cool so
so now it's about building confidence
and their ability to have an impact on
other people
as well but I have a question yeah is it
[Music]
it's time what do you mean like you know
they come to my workshop and seminar and
then I know they they're all my
Instagram followers too so they see my
content but say like you know eventually
you can help out the people you got your
message out
no goal is
but do they have
is it can I open them up a little bit
that idea well that's why it's important
to to Brand the event right like if you
look at movement makers okay movement
makers is for people who want to build a
movement yeah it's not just about we do
scary things like if I call it we do
scary things group then it'd be
completely different we would all go on
maybe different trips or Adventures or
whatever just doing scary things but
like no no we're here to build the
movement so if you're joining us because
you want to build a movement so what's
the name of your Workshop
uh video editing seminar for beginners
and
to have to build confidence for women I
think that's kind of so so the thing
that
that we need to put in there is about
you have a message for the world like
your message matters how to get your how
to record your message and get it out
to the world
so it's not you're going to be teaching
the video editing but the video I didn't
if they're only coming for video editing
stuff
then they may not even want to be on
camera themselves like Oh I thought I
was coming to do video editing I don't
want to I don't want to be in I think
it's a lot of women especially our age
I mean in my age they don't want to be
80 I would say they don't want to show
their face
so is that part of it
like is that part of the workshop can
you are you going to teach them how do
you want to force them I don't it's
really hard but I want to I should I
shouldn't force them but I want to just
like
so this is where it's like it's
attracting the right people right
because if you were in
movement makers and you didn't want to
be on camera like you're you're you're
not a right fit for what we're trying to
do here like you want you can give them
baby steps like the Union Station
homework that I gave you the first time
you know we connected in person
was a baby step like was it baby step oh
really but now I wouldn't give you that
homework because you're capable of doing
that I would give you a much bigger step
that was a big step for me but yeah yeah
okay listen you go at the moment there
was go to Union Station and like make a
quick video now we're here talking about
you delivering a workshop Halfway Around
the World to women and teaching them
things like the Yuko from a few years
ago wouldn't have even thought that that
was possible right no not at all so so
you level people up like the homework
assignment gets bigger because the
person has grown but
making that uh part of the process is
that hey like you have a message and the
confidence comes out from recording
yourself and I'll show you how to make a
good video around it
so in the you attract the right people
in who want to learn how to do the thing
that you want to ideally put in because
if it's if it's labeled as video editing
Workshop you can get people who come in
who want to learn how to edit videos but
they may never want to be in front of
the camera
yeah so you're not bringing the people
in for the thing that you actually want
to be helping them with the most which
is how do you get on camera and share
your message with the world and video
editing
is a easy way to
to make your videos look better
right
so it's like how do we package how do we
label what do we call this Workshop that
it's about you having a voice and we
need to get that voice out
so it's not just you by yourself we're
getting this voice out to the world
I don't know well something around that
like in the labeling of the work like
what we call the workshop
it's like you have a message that
matters let me show you how to get it to
the world yeah yeah something around
that and I don't know how that
translates to Japanese and like cultural
differences and what the you know the
the language might you know actually
mean and what would resonate with them
but something along the lines of that as
opposed to calling in a video editing
Workshop I just don't want yeah I know
what you mean I just don't want to do
just video editing right but right so
how it's been labeled right now is it
sounds like it's a video editor yeah
yeah right which is part of what you're
going to do but the video editing on its
own is not enough it's like why are we
why are we editing a video because you
have a message that we want to get out
to the world yes there's a one lady
she's been to my zoom I I've done it a
couple times video editing
soon
there was a lady she she was like normal
like you know working corporate lady but
she was afraid of showing her spiritual
side she loves to go to like you know
just shrines and she believes in you
believes in UFOs and she she loved the
oceans and get the energy things but now
she's starting to show not her face but
she's starting to kind of show slowly
her what she really cares about what she
really liked her message with videos
that made me feel so happy she's not
even her face is not even show it
so
that maybe if I just like let the the
people comes to the house let them just
have that side like tap into their size
it's still okay without showing face
as long as they're getting growth like
oh okay as long as they're getting broke
I got it when you
when you get a group of people together
when you don't understand and you've
come to some of my events you've seen it
right you you help take people to a new
level of confidence and motivation
and that's great
but unless you do something while you're
in that state of confidence and
motivation you go home and you fall back
down to where you were yeah right like
you probably wouldn't have on your own
gone through Union Station and done this
thing except for the fact that I
challenge you to go off and do it right
so you they're going to come and meet
you okay they're going to meet each
other like it's also great to meet each
other who like oh my gosh you're also
trying to do this thing I don't know
anybody most people don't have they're
not married to somebody who who believes
in this who understands this is you're
crazy they don't know their kids are
making fun of them like now they have
other people very much who who are like
them right so they're meeting together
for the first time finally found their
tribe they're getting inspiration from
you and you're going to take their
confidence to a new level
together but after three hours
they're going to go home they're going
to fall back down to where they were and
it's just going to be this little blip
unless you get them to do something
unless I get them to do something to do
something like the union stations like
you did that like oh my gosh I did that
yeah so now that's still I still like
gives me smile I did that right and so
it's not just a temporary motivation
it's that you use that motivation to
create something new
so
it starts with you labeling and
packaging the workshop better so it's
around you having a message that we want
to share you've got to you you have an
important message let me help you share
it
and that's what the workshop is all
about and then you're going to teach
them how to do video editing so that
they can yeah they can do it you can
teach them skills so it's not just a
motivational three hours of you you can
do it you can do it like you're going to
show them how to actually do it right
yeah
um so that will now at the beginning
you're you're the people who you're
bringing in the four people or probably
people who already know you they're
already part of your audience so you
could call it anything you could call it
workshop with Yuko and they would show
up right but this becomes it's good
practice so that ideally we're starting
to get people to come in who have no
idea who you are
and we're attracting the right kind of
people in so it's not a video editing
Workshop it's a workshop on finding your
voice and sharing it with the world yes
yeah right yeah so they get our last two
spots or to open it up to eight people
or ten people or the next city is 20
people or whatever you'll end up wanting
to do
right when I did my tour
uh a good chunk of the people who came
out had no idea who I was really yeah or
like or their friend brought them along
like what are we here to learn yeah
um which is good so you're reaching new
people not just people who already know
who you are yeah and we had some
hardcore fans who followed you know us
around the different cities and stuff
too but uh
so we start with labeling the workshop
better
if you have three hours
it's a little tight
so I would think maybe there's a way to
expand it but could you do a half day
could you make it a little bit longer
but if you're constrained what I would
say is
to have a point where you're
you're leading with the message so the
first part is
helping them feel confident because
when people first show up think of when
you first came here you're nervous yes
yes awkward it's like awkward I don't
know anybody did I just make a huge
mistake what am I doing here is it crazy
I don't belong here I'm not this kind of
person what's happening and so like when
somebody is feeling like that you can't
tell them go make a video and post it
right there's no way so how do I do that
well but that becomes a job in the in
the first whether it's half hour first
hour of the session your your building
up
their confidence you're helping them
find their voice
do you have any technique you want the
people the people you start by changing
the perspective again okay like when you
said every time I'm nervous and every
time I'm scared to make a video or to do
the homework that everyone gives me or
whatever I think of if one woman can
learn from this yeah and that gives you
the courage and the strength to then go
off and do the thing even if it sucks
even if it's no good whatever you're
still just gonna do it because it might
serve one person that's a technique you
can teach that technique oh oh okay so
all the women who are coming in they're
nervous they're afraid they're worried
that they're in the wrong spot that they
don't belong they're not good enough
like what did I just make a huge mistake
all of these feelings right
so you you help remind them that they
have a story
you can even go if it's only six people
you can even quickly go around it's like
what is your story why are you here
like in a small group you can do a lot
more than if you have 100 people
it's not as intimate right review a
thousand people or whatever it's
definitely not as intimate but even just
like why are you here what's your
message as a quick around the room I
like the idea because if you know what
their message is
anytime there's resistance
you push them on their message
so push yeah so for example if your
messages I want women to feel more
confident yeah
that's what you want to you want people
to do cool so now anytime I give you
homework and you say oh I don't know if
I can do that it's like well you could
you want women to feel more confident
like I have the language to push you
because I know what matters to you okay
for me
I like helping women feel more confident
but it's like not the main things if if
I was struggling with something I don't
know if I want to do it or not or I'm
like I'm in my own head in my own way
and you said hey Evan but it might help
women feel more confident
that may not be a good enough reason for
me to then go off and do the thing but
it's a good enough reason for you
because that's your yes because if
you're not confident and it's horrible
like it's it's if you gotta live if you
don't have a confident and people is
going to be pushing you all over you and
you're not happy
so it's start the event by having
everybody go around and share their why
like share this what is their story what
is their why why do they want to make
content
who do they want to inspire what's their
message to the world and in them sharing
it gives them a little more confidence
and in hearing what the other women are
sharing too it gives everybody even more
confidence you can start and share what
your why is
yeah that's a starting point but then
you have them start to participate so
then they start to feel like they belong
and that what they're doing matters is
meaningful they should be here they
belong right
um
I think you need to have some kind of
not just q a but
doing it together
doing it together
my story well I think they need to
actually film a video like you film a
video in the workshop in the workshop so
you can tell them okay so before you
come I need you to think about what your
story is cool I'll give them homework
yeah and like download these apps
download this app download this app that
whatever you're using like what apps
you're using
a free seminar
seminar before I left for Japan I mean
Canada too but what do they need to
install on their phone just cap cut cap
cut cool so like figure out what your
story is yeah and get cap cut installed
on your phone okay
I'll give them because you don't want
people when they're in the workshop what
do I need to download where is oh my
data is not working oh that's a waste of
time it's a waste of time yeah right
you're losing momentum it's like get
that get that done everything before
they come okay and then instead of just
doing Q a you have them actually make a
video so you start with them okay
sharing what their story is and who they
want to inspire who they want to serve
okay and then you say okay so now we're
going to make a really quick video I
expect it to suck it's going to be
terrible but I'm going to show you how
to make a video and then edit it to get
it out to the world and have an impact
on people it's it's a workshop yeah
you're right so let's do something yeah
so whether it's them filming themselves
or whether they want to film
the table or their foot or their
penciled or like whatever if they're not
comfortable in front of the camera yet
but they're filming something quick yes
like just making the just filming that
might take 20 minutes of course I've
taught couple times on Zoom yeah just
like okay this is how you cut it and
took like to teach for four ladies over
50s yeah
it takes like 20 but just to film it not
even to teach how to do the edits just
to finish yeah so you say make a 20
second video yeah of
you can make a 20 second video of your
message to the world
so like what they just went around
and asked like you went around the table
and asked them like why are you here
what's your message right cool now I
want you to make a 20 second video
we're going to together and you don't
have to post it don't worry like it's
just it's just practice Yeah so we're
we're sorry the phone yeah and talk
talk ideally I do if they're not willing
to do that then film a tree or film yeah
the voice so we can hear something of
what is your message what do you want
people to learn right what is your you
can say like what's your message to the
to younger you what's what's your
message to your young to your 19 year
old self like give them some kind of
easy prompt
okay because the more now they're
nervous now they're stressed out now
they're like oh my gosh I don't know if
I can do this and so the the less clear
you are the more options you give them
the harder it is for them to narrow
something down it is right yeah so even
something simple like that what is your
message to your 19 year old self to make
that video simple is very good right
yeah so that she said okay so everybody
now you're gonna go spend 15 minutes go
somewhere go outside find a little
corner because they don't want to film
all next to each other like when that
person is judging me yeah because it's a
tiny room actually yeah so like go
outside or whatever and film your yeah
15 second 22nd 32nd what's your message
to your 19 year old self
right and then you can even go around
and help them as we go around like we
did that here I remember right yeah Alex
went around and like gave feedback on
what you're doing
and it doesn't have to be perfect and
just the fact that they're recording
anything for most people is already a
win because they haven't recorded
anything
right then they come back and now you
have a video to work with it's like okay
so here's your videos right cool
expected to suck awesome don't worry
about that now we're going to open up
cap cut and we're going to
do this and do that and do this and do
that and then you're working with them
to actually
make a video but the video is not some
theoretical idea of a video it's their
actual message that they're working with
to try to make it better and put
captions on and put animations and
coloring and whatever else you're going
to teach them yes how to do oh okay that
would be so much fun though yeah and
then that becomes a q a part of it too
because as they're struggling to do it
like where is that button or how do I do
this or what if I wanted to add this
then you can show them how to do it okay
and then you end it with the reminder
again of why they're here it's like your
job is to challenge
um their perspective yeah so they're
coming in because they have a message
for the world
and you're ending with they have a
message for the world because you
started with that they got motivated
they shared their story they got excited
you know like okay maybe I can do this
then they made a video
and then they just spent an hour and a
half of learning how to edit and cut and
the captions and all this stuff now
they're back into like their head mode
of trying to figure this stuff out so
you have to before you end bring it back
to why we're here what the big picture
is again give them more confidence that
they have a message
for the world and the most important
thing is that they start creating
content so that people can learn from
them
so like perspective perspective and
sandwich with the skills in between
oh
skills
let's see sandwiches sandwich it's like
you're you're having turkey sandwich
this morning now we're having our
sandwiches
for how to run a workshop yeah because
you want them leaving
I like that feeling great not leaving
feeling stressed out about all the
skills and like I didn't get it I don't
know how to do the captions and like
some people will end up being ahead of
others and they may not especially in a
three-hour window it's not very long so
they they may not have something like
they're super happy with so we need to
reward them for the progress that they
made yeah and then remind them that
their story matters again yeah right
yeah
um recognizing them go around the table
and like what did you learn what was
your biggest takeaway or what's your
next step or how often you're going to
make content yeah just so that they feel
powerful again confident again I want to
them to read General after the seminar I
wanted them to regenerate generate
generally generate right the feel
okay I'll do it I'll do it oh okay I
want to do it again again because lots
of people they kind of when they walked
out
their motivations and you know feelings
just go down down
so I have some people they gone to they
come to the seminar but just maybe that
point they're not being keep consistent
yeah so I find it throughout like you
have helped me out to be consistent
right so the first step is the hardest
step it's very hard right like people
will take a decade to take the first
step oh very much it took me like what
40 some years it's like the first step
it's crazy how long it takes to take the
first step so that's why you need to do
the first step with them like hold their
hand and you do the first step together
I
know so that when you went and did the
unionization thing yeah then you said it
didn't kill me right it's like the voice
of your head this is gonna kill me like
it's not gonna kill you you're just
going to a train station you're making a
video like it's not gonna kill you right
but but this is this is what people are
thinking that it's some big impossible
thing so the best thing you can teach is
not just the skills and not just
answering people's questions but to
actually do the thing with them yeah
so let's film a video together so like
that that's the most important part of
the workshop is that they actually film
something they did something
I love that so yeah yeah so if we call
it you know you've got a message for the
world but let's I'll help you get it out
there
so The Branding the titling of the
workshop the description of the workshop
so the people are expecting this coming
in you're attracting people who want to
get a message out to people as opposed
to just a video editing Workshop the
Challenger perspective and find out you
know why they're here what their message
is and encourage them and cheer them on
and support them
then they make a video then you edit the
video
on a new encourage and support and
remind of the mission again at the end
and if you want to add a bonus it's like
you can partner them up accountability
group like okay the next homework is you
got to make
three videos next week
and partner people up to be
accountability Buddies
to go off and do it so that you're
staying consistent because the first
step like is the hardest thing
yeah that's exciting
very exciting I'm nervous but
yeah I'm very happy with myself too like
you know so it's small but it's okay
the first the first Workshop I did was
four people three people four people I
don't remember now uh uh at the YMCA
here in Toronto yeah I knew it like me
now I just like you know what even if
zero people sign up zero people this is
gonna be my story
yeah I felt like used to be I just like
oh what if nobody comes I don't think I
should do it that
thought was bigger I but now
somehow because I built the confidence
so now I'm just like you know what I if
I don't do it like you know I mean just
do it and then zero people it's okay and
if nobody showed up if nobody I have
like you know the seminar room and
nobody just by myself
I think I'm going to do IG live anyway
or something you know no people is
actually not the worst the worst is one
person you know it's like nobody shows
up well because if nobody shows up you
can go home right it's like it's not the
end of the world nobody showed up it's
fine nobody knows what happened but it's
like if one person shows up it's like oh
it's like I hosted this event and you're
the only one here okay I can't go home
yeah I gotta stay here this is awkward
okay let's help you but I love I love
the intimate I love the one-on-ones me
too I love the groups I love the big
groups yeah I love the seminars like
it's all it's all serving and I'll help
you
um I would definitely share that you're
nervous
like share your story share that before
you ask them to share what they're here
for what their purpose is
share yours like hey I'm actually really
nervous to be here
and
I'm still doing it right that will
encourage that it's inspirational right
because if you're if you're if you're
perfect and it's harder to learn from
you like oh well easy for you Yuko
you're not you don't know what it's like
to be nervous like yeah I know I like
even being here yeah I'm nervous right
um I remember I was at a a video event
and there were these two brothers who
were speaking together okay okay who are
friends of mine and one of them was
seasoned and had like done tons of
events and presentations and the other
guy was his very first time ever doing a
presentation and they're on the main
stage they got a thousand people Plus in
the room and he's like freaking out his
brother and brother may not have been
making it better he's like oh yeah this
is easy and it's like easy for you I'm
I'm struggling yeah and I told them to
just go out and actually say that you're
nervous
like just get on stage yeah and say I'm
nervous like this is my first time ever
speaking and I'm really nervous to be
here
because it makes you a lot more
relatable yes yeah and so so he said
that and some people clapped them up you
know for even admitting that and then at
the end he got so much love from
people's like that was your that was
amazing I can't believe that was your
first time ever doing it and by him
admitting it it relieved the pressure of
having to be perfect
right it's actually more of an
inspiration that you're willing to get
up there and risk failing yes then if it
was super easy for you to go off and do
yeah so not being perfect
yeah and sharing like if you're really
nervous then you share that you're
really nervous yeah right because my one
word is beer
you have to show up
so I'm nervous and I am I I can say I
don't pretend that I'm I have confidence
confident so I'm
you know I can say for sure like I'm
nervous
and then I think IG live
helping me a lot to a lot
just you know I still nervous but it's
okay to be nervous tell myself it's okay
to be nervous so whatever so I mean
there's lots in there one
um
how do you get more confidence well
because you're doing the things that
make you feel nervous right yes every
time you do something that you you're
afraid of you build a little more
confidence in yourself right so you can
explain that like why am I doing this if
I'm really nervous well because I want
to build my confidence to a new level
and I can only do that by doing things
that make me feel nervous yes if IG live
helped you you can also do a quick IG
live in the room oh okay right it's like
hey we're here
you know Osaka Osaka we're here in Osaka
yeah I mean it could all be in Japanese
anyway and maybe most people wouldn't
understand what you're I've tuned into a
couple of your IG lives and it's all in
Japanese like I don't know what's
happening but hey you go that's great
yeah he sent me a love right so it
doesn't matter yeah I'm just doing like
a street outside guy in the street I can
start doing no even in the room too
after after everybody told their story
before you have them like so you lead
you're going to share your story you ask
them for their story what their message
is after you could before you ask them
to make a video you could do a group IG
live where like you're at the front and
you have your four or six people at the
table it's like hey I'm here in Osaka
I'm teaching my women's world and and
all of these amazing women have an
amazing story to share with the world
and here's whoever and her her mission
is they don't even have to say anything
they could even just wave and say hi but
they don't like you can explain for them
but now they're on camera
they're on camera they're on camera
they're nervous like oh my God I'm going
to be next but they're we're starting to
drill and practice a thing like that
wasn't actually that bad and hey now
we're on camera you don't kill me right
it didn't kill me right maybe I could do
this myself but why it's important is
because the things that helped you
will help other people I believe that
yeah yeah and so by you explaining how
it helped you and telling your story it
inspires other people so if IG lives
helped you yeah do IG lives with them so
it helps them if reminding yourself that
if this video helps one woman feel more
confident it's worth it that's a
strategy that helped you you can teach
that to the woman so it helps them as
well so whatever whatever helped you
in your journey and process you can then
teach that it helps them as well
Bernie
I'm so valuable
feel confident
that's great
I want to other women to feel that way
because it hurts me that women said you
know I'm not valuable I don't have any
confidence I am just nothing
I'm just like it's just like no you're
not you know circling back on why you
know our conversation in the beginning
were you coming back to when you were
here four years ago whenever the first
time you came in and you had that Union
Station challenge that Yuka would have
never said I feel so valuable never
and who is this huco now
right yeah I keep updating I guess
and that's amazing that's great and
there's still more levels to go through
right so now you're doing this one
Workshop you feel nervous cool but then
once you do that you can do like the
reason why I did my tour because I was
really afraid to do yes speaking yes I
said okay I'm gonna I'm gonna do the
thing I'm most terrified about and I'm
gonna go speak every four days
I'm going to host my own workshop and
speak every four days and who knows that
people are going to show up and that
made you nervous yeah
it was nerve-wracking to go on because I
was I'd never done my own event in brand
new cities okay okay and I was afraid
people would show up in in states too
right right in the U.S yeah I was afraid
nobody would show up I was afraid I
wouldn't be good I was afraid I wouldn't
have a good man I'm afraid I didn't know
like what would happen I didn't know
so
um
what did you tell yourself before event
I mean show like for me it's always it's
always it's a balance of two one is that
I'm here to serve and I want to help
people that's the hug it's a hug and a
push right so the hug is I want to serve
there's one person here who might learn
from my message so I have to show up for
that person the push is I want to do the
things that I'm afraid of yeah
that like being afraid is not a good
enough reason so I have to go off and do
it and I'd lean on both some some in
different percentages you know like
before one event I might be 80 20 the
other one I might be 20 80 depending on
how I'm feeling sometimes service is the
thing that gets me the most and
sometimes I no because I'm afraid I have
to do it
about a so we did 23 cities in 90 days
90 days yeah
about a third of the way through I
wasn't scared anymore
so like a third of the way through the
trip I wasn't scared to get up on stage
and do the thing so you've gone to uh
Next Level yeah so now okay what's the
next level
so when we got to I think it was la
by the time we got to La like I wasn't I
wasn't scared of doing nothing because
I've been doing every four days I wasn't
scared anymore so then in La I decided
to go all q a
no structure no format I had my like
presentation down yeah I'm gonna throw
away the presentation just go q a and
see what happens
like maybe nobody has a question maybe
it's gonna suck I don't know and I still
ended I mean it was great I thought I
thought it was great
um and we still covered most of the same
material yes but we just did it through
q a format instead of my usual structure
yeah and that really scared me
so hey that's the next that's the next
level up and then so that was the next
month okay and then the last month I
broke my neck I remember that yeah the
castle this is like do we do we continue
on the tour or not do we keep going or
not
um it was it was me Nina and Danny
for 90 days I remember that yeah
yeah I I've watched every single
you know the live and like just
everything you post I've but then that
last month I had a like I had a
concussion I had a broken neck I was in
Crazy pain I couldn't help at all right
I couldn't drive so now Nina has to
drive this like this Arena was driving
big Danny had to like carry everything
all of my luggage and like everything
and just like Workhorse like he was
already filming and setting up in every
in every shop and editing on the off
days and like oh and can you also carry
all of the luggage to you know it's like
insane amounts of work and uh and we all
pulled through and did it right and so
that became
the last month that was of a challenge
now I didn't intentionally break my neck
just to make it more difficult but
that's how we level up it's like things
either things happen to us or we we put
things in place like going on the tour
was was the start of the level up going
all q a was the next level up and then
breaking my neck and deciding to
continue it was like Beyond The Next
Level though well it's like and I look
back on this like I did that that's
crazy I can't believe that I did that
right and then you were saying this is
the best oh that's the best hospital bed
this is the best
and it went live with a concussion yeah
I don't even know what I said I looked
like I was dying because I said I was
going to go live every day on the tour
yeah so we went live for seven minutes
or something from the hospital
uh because I said I was gonna go live
every day right so now this is your next
level up right so you're gonna go to
Osaka you're going to do your Workshop
you're gonna help four or six or ten
every people sign up and then it's okay
well what's next maybe maybe uh
workshops in Canada maybe you do your
own tour in English I don't know but
it's funny at the beginning of pandemic
I did IG live with you and you you were
coaching on on IG diet but you said
maybe you're gonna have eventually
you're gonna have like tour like be
yourself tour
right now you're doing it it's happening
first stop is in Japan this is great
you're already getting you're starting
an international oh my gosh you must be
a psychic I don't know you I don't know
but it's it's wind up video editing I
found it's more comfortable I can teach
women to be to have more confidence be
themselves because I I can be more I I
feel more confident I can be myself by
doing through video editing posting yeah
so it's not just a usual like women you
should have more confidence not like
regular seminar seminar I've done it but
I didn't feel it
but by teaching video editing that tool
really helped me out
again inside of that the biggest thing
will be not just teaching the editing
but having them record a video having
them recorded because when you can see
the the tears in their eyes or the oh my
gosh I can't believe I did this like
that's that's why they're there at the
workshop yeah not to learn how to edit a
video but to start to get their message
out and that you help them take that
first step
will be something they remember forever
like you're never going to forget the
Union Station never homework right but
now you're going to be that person for
yeah for them who show up yeah that
would be so nice anyway I'm so excited
every time I see you you're you're
you're leveling up thank you you're
doing new things bigger things having a
bigger impact and super excited to hear
how your first stop of the world tour
goes World Tour yes the other side of
the world right so thank you thank you
thank you Evan awesome awesome coaching
as always yeah I really appreciate it
thank you so much Evan cool yes to see
me coaching another entrepreneur
one-on-one check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe
you there